les chéris on va aussi vous connaissez
bien invité du jour on va jouer à lequel
vous avez des pancartes et demi je vous
propose à michael ou allemand lequel des
deux a été chroniqueur sur france inter
qui était chroniqueur sur france inter
alban ou michael hall banque annonce
qu'en 2009 ouais avec monsieur à
frédéric lopez exactement on a retrouvé
un extrait où tu joues une professeur de
collège
ah oui alors est ce que tu as envie
d'une garde robe si je m'en sors bien là
maintenant c'est par des moments
difficiles je le vaux j'ai 33 ans
professeur de français dans une zep à
dammarie les lys
alors comme vous le savez écrire c'était
la rentrée et franchement quand je vois
comment s'est passé ma première journée
je sais pas si je vais tenir le couloir
est là faut vraiment que le gouvernement
passe quelque chose on peut pas rester
comme ça ah non là on a plus d'effectifs
les élèves sont de plus en plus
dangereux alors c'est vrai que cette
année on équipés de fusils à pompe et
gilet pare balles mais j'ai peur ça
suffise pas
[Applaudissements]
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup le
projet capillaire en profites t'elle à
l'époque oui qu'est ce qui s'est passé
je sais pas d'un coup c'est le succès
plus de cheveux ça te ont cependant vu
toi tu arrivé à un niveau physique où
tout va oh c'est beau ce que tu connais
j'ai envie de refaire un goûter lequel
des deux s'est fait rouler une pelle par
vincent moscato
alors c'est qui ça c'est lequel
alors à michael kelly a dû michael
michael le problème c'est que je peux
pas corroborées alors il parait cette
histoire tu avais raconté que vincent
moscato et avait roulé une pelle à saint
barth dans une soirée ah oui il n'avait
pas trop assumer ah oui c'est vrai alors
c'est vrai quoi cette histoire on a les
images non non non les appartenant non
non c'est aux supports ont décollé ça te
laisse un bon souvenir mais oui alors
c'est la suite qui était un peu plus dur
parce que vincent essaie de me montrer
comment il se faisait une entrée en
mêlée quand il était il était pliée et
il m'a mis un coup de casque et je pense
que je suis resté inconscient pendant je
sais pas deux minutes quoi ouais parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas pu venir dont il
devint la remplacer je suis en clientèle
[Rires]
je termine de clients lequel des deux
est fan de céline dion moi aussi je suis
comme toi à ces masses c'est quoi ta
chanson préférée de senna je sais pas si
c'est pas des lois un fmi redoute minima
l'air de lui plaire ce que put champ
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
réponse internationale à la 2e là nous a
fait une gastro la visualiser là les
païens belle à ces chiens et tout pour
qu'elle regarde j'attends va la
rencontrer en vrai c'est un bisou mais
elle est bientôt en concert à paris au
mois de juillet je voulais dire
rencontrer tous ces lignes oui bien sûr
mais on la rencontre toujours avant les
concerts pas après après hilarant il lui
met les chiens mais en compte faute elle
veut on est la radio des comptes en a b
c comme toutes les grandes cantatrices
et c'est généralement après le concert
elle rentre immédiatement
alors un conseil vous voulez du
rencontrez-vous oui bien sûr à vous
écouter et ben on a parlé elle m'avait
raconté la chanson titanic parce qu'elle
voulait pas l'enregistrer au départ elle
c'est la première et heureusement crohn
et était là et j'ai bien connu rené
d'ailleurs café avant c'est elle avait
bu du café avant est bon c'est pas ça
moi et penser que la note 'aaa' n'avait
pas la sortir aller mais par ce titre
elle y croyait pas plus que ça et elle
voulait vrai c'est vrai qu'elle a refusé
à le raconter mais il croit que les
canons studio céline elle l'a fait à
l'arraché elle n'a pas la rage
je fais pour faire payer à la maquette
exams et même quand elle chante une
maquette c'est tellement bien une prise
les gens considéraient ce que tu vas sur
plusieurs pistes à canons non je suis
toujours sur ses lignes avec l'histoire
on lui propose en fait rené entend
parler qu'un film qui va bouleverser le
monde entier qui s'appelle titanic et il
veut que ce soit sa femme qui chante la
chanson et les génériques de l'âge d'or
à la céline dion et rené insiste elle
veut pas y aller elle a un problème de
voix parce qu'elle trouve qu'elle chante
mal quand elle prend du café elle aime
pas ça le salut trouble la voix c'est ce
que raconte albert est exact elle va
quand même faire la maquette
elle y va quand même et même quand elle
chante mal tout le monde est médusé de
céline yoda
sa photo avec un flotteur
c'est moi qu'elle regarde dit des
saloperies
donc après ça a été un succès oui et
puis ils ont ils ont ils ont décidé
finalement la voie était tellement
probante qu'ils ont dit on l'a gardée
c'est pas possible ça peut être qu'elle
est le succès était planétaire ces 20
millions de disques un quand même notre
histoire une autre histoire de
l'audience on prenait l'intervalle une
autre chanson quoi de les ramener mon
pâté pour la fin du goûter non il faut
absolument qu'ils rencontrent ces lignes
on t'en mets d'abord sa nouvelle
personne étape à une autre histoire mais
notre histoire de qui de quoi de manades
chanteur d'essence ont eu ma chanson
qu'est ce que tu aimes bien comme
chanson on a affaire crois que c'est un
médicament alli des alizés alors j'ai eu
l'idée c'est quoi c'est marie je te
promets ta chanson préférée d'hallyday
ça je prends je te promets alors comment
il arrive à te promets dîner avec jean
jacques goldman
parce que c'est un autre c'est l'auteur
compositeur de la chanson évidemment
elle est le grand talent de johnny c'est
de raconter sa vie à son auteur
compositeur ça c'est un grand grand
talent même si vide a écrit très peu de
chance on finalement me raconte sa vie
est en fait l'histoire je te promets
c'est un homme
enfin les photos actions et donc et il a
raconté son idée parce qu'il commençait
à séduire une très jeune femme ce moment
là et il est amoureux d'une jeune fille
avait quand même 20 ou 25 ans d'écart
non non c'était pas à laëtitia
izaguirre 10 c'est adeline soul and line
est un homme d'un homme de 40 ans
excusez moi vous il tait
omar sy c'était pour a dit oui là non je
te promets je t'aime excuse et c'est bon
alors il est donc c est là il a mis
goldman son talent aussi à goldman c'est
d'avoir remis quelque part la vie de
johnny et l'envi de séduire une très
jeune femme et lui faire des promesses
même si les 20 ans de plus qu'elle
ça c'est pas bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je peux faire deux heures participé
à la star ac
michael ou albert o la répartie 6 et
mika avec les bref cela n'était pas
candidat mais ta joie un magnifique
morceau au piano accompagné de vincent
desagnat c'était pas un morceau à 80 non
c'est un morceau de club mais je regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'était sympa à écouter
j'avais pas encore ça on attend prime
passé oui c'est vrai que j'ai pas sûr je
ne sais pas si c'était déjà possible à
l'époque je connais les mecs je ne sais
pas si mme que alors juste été un piano
à queue forcément il aime bien ça m'a
aidé alors je te le dis album tu es venu
a pas longtemps
oui mais le public nous a demandé de
remettre l'extrait de l'instit je pense
à ça n'a pas du tout d'abord on va
revoir cette chaîne
je la crois que c'est pour l'équipe de
robert le limage mon masque regardez
bien la course dans le mur d'une
question c'est celle ben ouais ça donne
regardez cette façon de jouer le mec
bourré et je le dis moi je la regarde
tous les matins je suis moins bien
[Musique]
[Rires]
ma vie
[Musique]
dans la tête
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas ça
un avant et un après bah oui oui on voit
qu'ils montent à la grille mon sais pas
pourquoi ça cache cache qui sont traqués
ils cherchent de l'aide
oui je suis un voisin mais caché si vous
auriez d'une baguette mais le meilleur
bien entendu c'est le passage dans
l'instit
quand tu te noies dans 20 centimes ont
extrait celui-là c'est le meilleur
les avances
[Musique]
babès
à
allez
allez marche bien devant toi regarde pas
les cascades
[Applaudissements]
l'enfant derrière qui est comme ça il
admis